but we're going to begin this hour with
stand up superstar that Sebastian
Maniscalco and Screen legend that would
be the one and only Robert De Niro thank
you very much the two entertainers first
joined forces on the film the Irishman
back in 2019 and now they're on the
screen together again this time in a new
comedy it's called about my father now
this movie is Loosely based on
maniscalco's relationship with his dad
Salvatore known as Salvo a hair stylist
in the Chicago area where Maniscalco
grew up so we caught up with Robert De
Niro Maniscalco and his dad a Chicago
Salon GC by George Charles thank you
George Charles for letting us take over
your salon for a bit to talk about the
movie but first we stopped by a nearby
sandwich shop for a very special
surprise
comedian Sebastian Maniscalco has sold
out Arenas across the country that was
working 18 hours a day I think I
formally met my dad when I was 18 years
old
his dad Salvatore Maniscalco is a common
theme in his acts so we decided to meet
up with him at this Chicago suburb Deli
in his neighborhood they have a very
special sandwich there we heard this is
where you can get a good Sebastian
maniscalcoaster you definitely heard
correct hi you guys how are you what do
you think Salvo when you come in and
there's a there's a sandwich named after
your son I can't believe it really I
can't I
what is it about him that you think is
so good I mean that him growing up and
hearing the stories of his childhood I
mean I have the exact same Stories the
eggplant sandwiches at lunch and the
kids would laugh at me like I I have
that the school wasn't responsible if
the veal piccata spoiled
know he's so good though I hear you got
some amazing
sandwiches
what's happening I'm so glad to see you
I gotta ask you what's the Reverend one
the sandwich
all right three Sebastian specials three
Sebastian specials okay
that tomato was fresh first excellent on
a sandwich I gotta tell you beautiful I
love to hear that Salva was he a funny
little kid he was always because he
loves stage yeah I mean when I see him
there I'm performing I can read his mind
say yes that's where I belong but now
you know he's funny but you're such a
big part of his act were you always
comfortable with it always comfortable
you were yes you know because why
because of the money
you can say anything about me tell us
about the relationship between the two
of you what it means to you family is a
major thing for me I mean as a father
it's life and Sebastian is highlighting
their father-son bond in his new movie
It's called about my father 50 years ago
I come to this country to give you a
better life was it a hard story to tell
for you not necessarily a heart it was
hard to perform
because I don't
know do that now I'm doing it with one
of the greatest actors who ever lived
enter Robert De Niro never ran on your
friends
always keep your mouth shut the academy
award-winning actor plays Sebastian's
father dial it down
the real Salvo has been a hair stylist
since the 60s so we sat down with this
Trio at a hair salon I was curious about
you Bob De Niro now that you played him
like if I wanted you to wash my hair
color my hair braid my hair could we go
in the back and you could do that no I'd
have to bring Salva with me
I was checking out your highlights on TV
so how did this come about Sebastian did
you say Dad I sure would like it if
Robert De Niro played me in a movie it
was Unreal that the man said yes because
you just don't think that Robert De Niro
is going to end up playing your father
it's something that is you know it was
like a dream come true you know I called
him he don't believe nothing right I'm
like De Niro's gonna play you he's like
yeah right come on I don't believe it
until I see it
hold on let me get my hearing aid
because I said it's impossible I said no
way I don't even know if you know what
was going on on our side you're just
doing movies and we're sitting over here
going this is the guy I had on my wall
as a kid so uh it was super exciting and
I wonder what it's like for you when you
hear people what you just said Sebastian
I had posters of you know movies of of
yours on his wall what is it like for
you to hear what you mean to so many
people
I I'm honored and flattered at the same
time I cringe a little bit why because
that makes me uncomfortable but but I'm
you know I'm not I'm not complaining
but do you know you're that good though
you got to know it no I mean like when
you watch yourself in a movie do you go
oh my God
I'm unbelievable
I know I often wonder that do you do you
look at yourself are you a hard critic
of yourself when you watch yourself on
screen yeah I mean I look at myself at
certain things I say oh God I can't look
at that part of it is for vanity but
excluding the vanity part what it is
that you're doing character-wise what
you're supposed to do what the task is
at hand
but there is a key scene in the end when
it's a very emotional scene between the
two of you
was that difficult for you Sebastian
that scene
yeah that was the scene that I was kind
of pining over the whole time I was on
set like I wouldn't have to get
emotional I'm gonna have to cry
something I've never done on on film I
go to him I said listen I need help here
I don't know what I'm doing and could
you help me out and he goes well you
know I didn't want to say anything I
don't know what your process is and I'm
like my process is just hope
hope this happens
um so but wait wait before you finish
you have a process when it's time for
you to cry I think that's all just one
thing is not to force anything or to try
and get it or pull push for it either
you have any adult the worst thing you
could do is push something that's not
there better that you don't do anything
and that that to me is the most
important sometimes you can't you know
it's like doing a play every night in a
certain performance some days you can
have it or nights and others you just
don't and you just but you're a
professional you go through it you do it
what did he say to you no no he did he
said think about your father when you do
this think about your father and then I
start I in the in the conversation it
got emotional between him and I and I
started crying in the conversation I go
I I gotta use this so I'm running crying
thinking about my dad come into the
scene crying right I do this scene right
and they yell cut all right again I'm
like again okay it's all like that so
um it it just taught me a lot about
getting to certain places while you're
acting yeah but you know at the Crux of
the movie it's a love story between
families and I ultimately think those of
us with adult children we want our
children to be proud of us and on the
reverse we want to be proud of them
don't you think yeah ultimately that's
the goal I mean now that I have a son
you know it it I I want him to look up
to me like I look up to my dad so now
that we're here in Chicago when I left
in 1998 2023 sitting in the salon
or my dad and uh sorry it's a
yeah it's a bit it's a big moment for me
and uh
I just I want to thank you for for being
uh playing my father and I want to thank
you for being the best father okay S4
and sometimes I don't
um
sometimes I don't reflect on things that
happen in my career and it's happening
right now on your show so I think about
this little boy that had Robert De Niro
as a poster in his wall I do think that
that's big that's big so did Robert De
Niro capture your essence oh yeah I did
a fantastic job I think okay I'm crying
too now see
I know that emotion at the end I think
it took everybody a surprise by surprise
including Sebastian said you know Gail
you don't have to use that part I go oh
no that's it that's going to be in
slow-mo but I have to say a special
thank you to Forza meats that did this
that has that Sebastian sandwich on the
menu the ingredients prosciutto barata
mozzarella arugula tomato pesto balsamic
hot geodinero
on French bread Mario and Tyler we thank
you and special thanks to the tree of
I'm gonna do something and talk the
table because they were all so touching
to me you see Robert De Niro really
doesn't like compliments no but I love
that he's like no he does Sebastian I
know but that's like a dinero moment
where you know one of the greatest
actors of his generation looks over and
sees somebody getting emotional yeah you
get a pat on the back from Robert no it
was very very very tender moment and the
movie by the way is really really really
good it looks terrific yeah it was very
very funny I love that they're all in
little salon chairs though with their
feet up their knees are high you'd
almost imagine like the big hair dryer
over their heads yeah it was great I do
love the fact that you know that at the
end of the day what you said Gail which
is that he had this man's picture
honestly I know and now he's playing and
now that man's picture on the wall knows
your name and your number yeah that's
pretty cool very cool